[Applaudissements]
il est minuit passé au bout d'un chemin
de campagne au Québec des agents de la
grrêtent une dizaine de migrants des
hommes des femmes des enfants qui
voulaient se rendre clandestinement aux
États-Unis à pied beaucoup de manque
parlent pour aller là-bas avant une ou
deux mais là c'est une petite faute
puis arrêter ici puis ce type de scène
se retraité en observe quotidiennement
Girard habite au bout du rangerstone à
proximité du village de la colle la
frontière est littéralement dans sa cour
depuis quelques semaines ce chemin est
devenu l'un des plus importants points
de passage clandestin au
québecin le midi parce que surtout la
nuit
ici des blocs de béton et plusieurs
caméras viennent d'être installées par
les autorités et vous avez peur que ça
devienne ici un nouveau chemin Roxane
mais peut-être à l'envers
tu peux participer ça c'est parler ça
c'est parler mais
c'est maintenant le calme plat alors
qu'environ un millier de migrants arrivé
chaque semaine avant la nouvelle entente
signée par Justin Trudeau et Joe Biden à
la fin mars il n'y en avait qu'une
vingtaine la semaine passée selon nos
informations la grcmm réduit ses
effectifs dans ce secteur à l'inverse
sont maintenant les sorties du Québec
qui occupaient inquiète les autorités il
suffit de passer quelques heures la nuit
pour s'en rendre compte devant nous
trois jeunes d'origine latino américaine
descendent d'un taxi et marche
tranquillement vers la frontière
téléphone en main l'un d'entre eux
semble en contact avec un complice pour
les récupérer de l'autre côté mais ce
qu'on puisse arrivera trop tard
c'est une voiture banalisée de la police
américaine qui les arrêtera devant notre
caméra le nombre de passages clandestins
depuis le Canada vers les États-Unis a
récemment explosé il y a eu plus de 730
arrestations en mars dans cette zone
autour du Québec près du double par
rapport à février et 12 fois plus qu'un
an plus tôt ce qui a poussé les
Américains à ajouter depuis un mois 25
ans supplémentaire pour patrouiller dans
ce secteur depuis la fermeture du chemin
Roxane il existe plusieurs chemins
populaires chez les pasteurs et les
migrants près d'une ferme en Estrie on
retrouve des vêtements des bottes et des
tucs
à dos on a trouvé des foulards au
terrain biberon avec du lait aux trois
quarts dedans
on veut des affaires qui se passe s'il
voit passer des migrants depuis
longtemps se résidente automne en
n'avait jamais vu autant
la voyait un temps en temps
selon des sources policières ce
phénomène de migration vers le sud a
même augmenté depuis la fermeture du
chemin Roxane des passages irréguliers
vont s'amplifier les mois et les années
à venir d'après cette expert il serait
nombreux à vouloir quitter le Canada il
y en a qui pensait que ce serait plus
facile au Canada comme demandeur d'asile
et on sait qu'il y a beaucoup
d'obstacles c'est difficile de prendre
un permis de travail c'est long les
délais
difficile de travailler donc il pense
que c'est plus facile probablement c'est
plus facile de vivre clandestinement aux
États-Unis au Canada d'autres migrants
estiment-ils utiliseraient également le
Canada comme porte d'entrée vers les
États-Unis les personnes qui peuvent se
permettre parce que c'est beaucoup plus
sécuritaire que la frontière mexicaine
vont essayer de passer par le Canada
avec des passeurs bien sûr on a vu
l'exemple ce qui s'est passé à quoi ça
ce n'est
avec les Indiens on sait qu'il y a une
filière là vraiment très organisée et le
niveau des Mexicains aussi même s'il se
Maroc ça met désormais fermé les
passages à la frontière can Ada
américaine sont donc loin d'être
terminés des chemins comme celui-ci il y
en a un petit peu partout le long de la
frontière surtout entre le Québec et les
états de New York et du Vermont certains
de ses chemins sont connus par les
migrants par des chauffeurs ou par des
passeurs mais d'autres restent pour
l'instant paisible mais pour combien de
temps encore c'est une question pour
l'instant sans réponse ici romain Suez
Radio-Canada le long de la frontière
Canado américaine